Damian Rice asking do you think you
could beat me with Stafford in 15
minutes versus 30 seconds
for twenty dollars oh but actually means
15 seconds versus three minutes
Maybe
he had twenty dollars is twenty dollars
okay I'll I'll do the Stafford challenge
good evening I feel like you're able to
make it on as much as I'd like lately
but still no content you Calvin and luck
wait 15 seconds to three minutes
oh dear
this is a very difficult 20 challenge
but I'll try
staffer Gava time
I feel like Damien Rice has done their
research
or have they
should just pre-move Bishop C5
H3 wow
okay threatening upon
we we have an interesting variation here
a very interesting variation
okay
I mean the the first several moves were
fine
uh like this is a fine approach
but
interestingly enough Bishop E2 is
actually the losing move
not not even blundering the queen
the bishop E2 is uh
it walks into the sign
and there have been like multiple Grand
Masters who've walked into the sign
against me
uh including former World women's
champion ghostinyuk
but kostinook actually beat me from this
position like the best approach is I
believe to take with bishop and then
some late D2
one more okay
give a second chance it's important to
learn from
the mistakes
yeah what's my hourly wage for Mac aim
if I won in like
how many seconds
maybe someone can calculate
cathol Greco says seventy two thousand
dollars an hour
I feel like that might be slightly off
oh wait let's give more time I forgot
about the timeouts
there we go okay
I was risky to play this let's not
pre-move
I feel like I remember lafong showing
like how to beat the staff around this
stream
I was showing that everything wins for
white
okay
yeah D3 is a much better move and now
it's it's not easy to
play this
but I'm gonna try
I'll still go for the Stafford ideas
I gotta go for it right
oh it's too much fun
this was my new career